Excuse me, pardon me, wrong way- AH FUCK
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
And welcome to the Toy Box.
Now as you can see by these...lovely gentlemen
or, or man and wife, maybe
with their, award winning smiles.
we're in for a bit of a- whoa fuck!
Hello?
I seemed ot have dropped in on my spine!
Oooooooohhhh no
Gems?
Oh
NOO
OH NO! *Weird monster cry/laughing*
DOOON'T GIGGLE AT ME! WHAT THE FUCK!?!?!
Why was my vision get all wiggy woggy?
Don't you dare, I just got in this! You can't be dickin' with me!
Oh man, this reminds me of that monkey game...
the monkey with all the knives for hands!
*Wookie sounds* AND MURDER FOR BRAINS!
Fuuuuck you! *More weird wookie sounds*
AH FUCK OFF! Okay, I hear you.
I hear you stippy stippy stompy!
OOOOOWHEEEEYYYY! Okay alright okay alright!
Oh fuck dude. Ewaay, is he behind me?
*In audible oh eh alright* we're off to a bad start here.
I'm about to lose my goddamn MIND!
okay alright okay
Getting gems- AH OOKAY! ALRIGHTY THEN!!!
Fuuuck meeeee
Jesum Christmas
*clink clonk monster feet*
What the hell is going on here?
*Growl*
ohboyohboyoh the cray HEY!!! YEAH-YA
Fucking hell.
Oh God oh God oh God!
Jesums (4x)
DID I MAKE IT!?
What do I do?
Please tell me that was actually what I was
supposed to do and I wasn't supposed to do something else that I didn't know I was doing?
Okay
Alright, everybody calm down
everybody calm down, this is not a big deal.
not a big deal
everything's fine!
we got off to a bit of a rocky start so...
everybody just calm there collective tits and we'll get over this.
so I think-I think I'm about to die...
oh fuck
so what am I suppose to do?
I got all your damn gems!
do I gotta find an exit? I bet that's what I gotta to do
okay
alright then, well he's
*Clinking feet*
hello?
Oooh, no.
eeehhh! DOOR?
*High pitched voice* OOOHHH
goood!
Great! I found a door.
let me just clap my own back! *slaps chest?*
fuck
why am I supposed to do this?
Oh, good, water. I don't know what that does for me but is it purifying?
will it get rid of the demo-oookay?
*Wub, wub, wub*
Alright, I guess we're just gonna continue on our gem collecting adventure
dat sounds good to meee
I can't wait to see where this road lead meeee!
K. Anyway.
Just gonna *MOOOOO* DON'T DO THAT!!
DOOON'T
NOOO
eway boopi loop
just like getting rupees in Zelda
OHAA Fucking hell. Alright then
it's not like Zelda...
It's like... (pacman?)
Breath of The Wild, DAMN IT still Zelda!
Ok. OHEY WOAHOO!
Alrighty then!
Can you not do that, THAT'D BE GREAT, OH GOD!
*Clinky walks away...veeery slowly*
Ok. I guess I'm fine then, I guess I've got nothing to worry about.
Goddamn it.
It's not going well for me.
woaaaaa..
*Incoherent Mark noises*
OKAY ALRIGHT OKAY!
CAN I BRIBE YOU WITH GEMS?!
If i give you gems will you leave me alone?
Please no?
Oh god he's right behind me!
WOA he's right behind me!
okay, boodle boop, boodle boop, boodle boop!
*boodle doop intensifies*
FIDDLE FADDEL
Oh fiddle faddel
Fiddle faddel fiddle faddel
Piddle paddel
Two gems left? I don't know where these gems are
God dammit I don't know where he went
Can i see any thing?
yeesh
YEESV
hugv
Blegh, Eugh
Okay so these two gems are hiding around somewhere
so i need to find them
oh oh F*ck oh F*ck
Still need to find them!
I FOUND ONE AND TWO!
skip to ma loo! here we go!
oh oh okay alright then
We're good we're good We're good WE'RE GOOOOD!
Frick-a-dick I don't know why I'm doing this.
Why am I in these catacombs
It's like Vanish or SCP
It just thew me into the nothingness with the knife monsters
ugh
*evil chewbacca cow*
Fucking don't do that to me
No I don't want any of that
I don't want any
OH AH OH *unintelligible yelling*
*chewbacca cow*
Fuck you! And fuck me!
Ugh, but not in that order!
Okay, alright, good!
Skee-ba-dee-deep-bop-ba-deep-bop-beep-bo
Bleh-ba-de-boop-boop-badoop-boop
oH IT'S THE MOTHERLOAD!!!
*turkey gobbling*
oH GOD IT'S A TRAP! IT WAS ALWAYS A TRAP!!
My charm and good looks won out!
Okay, so you don't wanna mess with me! You've heard about me....
I know, MarkiPLIER. Very "professional" horror game player.
I'M KNOWN *voice crack* IN MANY CIRCLES!
Don't mind my prepubescent voice crack!
'Scuse me, pardon me, wrong way.
AHHH FUCK!
Fucking hell.
Oh thanks. You just popped up, and then popped away... I don't actually need to worry about you staying and killing me
Oh man. Fuck.
That got me good. I dunno why.
SpoOkY
Alright, let's try this again.
Give it another go
Oh good, it started me where I left off again.
Alright, I get your recipe here. I'm just gonna collect *terrifying bull screams* what's mine and then go on my way.
Okay where's the mothERLOAD?
I feel like I just default onto the same paths that neVERMIND THERE'S DIFFERENT
There's different. I'm an idiot.
I went back to the beginning somehow.
Don't ask me how I did it, I couldn't reproduce it if I tried.
Woah boy
*Mark screaming in terror*
Okay, alright. He's behind me.
Aye! It's the motHERLOAD
Oh boy oh boy! NOOO
Fuck.
Alrighty then,  well that was scary. Let's try one more time.
Doodloo doodloo
Yeah you're gonna giggle your giggle.
Yeah get your laughs outta the way!
Markimoo is here to play and you ain't gonna stay!
Neither am I for that matter, but that's another story entirely.
oH FUCKING GODDAMIT
I like once more. I like how it sounds like I'm getting punched in the face every time I start this son of a bitch.
Alright here we go *angry bull screams*
Yeah I know, it's the wrong way to go.
I's a loop-de-loop of death (by dismemberment preferably)!
STAHP LAUGHING
You hear me- AYE N-N-N-NO! N-N-N-NO! I'll come back for the motherLOAD
I CAME TO THE MOTHERLOAD ALREADY
DIDN'T MEAN TO DO THIS I'M SORRY
*Mark screaming unintelligibly*
Fuck a duck and then fuck you
Okay. Alright. Seems okay!
Aw shi- fuck you.
Didn't even know you were that close to me
It's getting harder as I go along and I don't know why.
But, I'm a "professional"!!!
*angry bull noises*
"Professional" video gamer!!
of epic proportions! OF EPIC PROPORTIONS!
NEH! DON'T LAUGH AT ME
I'm very sensitive.
Okay I'll come to the motherLOAD like GODDAMMIT I CAME RIGHT BACK TO THE MOTHERLOAD
How do I keep getting back here?!
I don't intend for this!
You think you can sneak on me?
You think you can sneak on ME?
I've learned from my MOM!
I know how to avoid monsters likE YOU!
My mother's love will protect me!
Just.... gonna go over here.
MY MOTHER'S LOVE WILL PROTECT ME!
Okay
Here we go
Skedaddle
Time for skedadLE
AHH SKEDADDLE
Aw.. my mother's lov- ah fuck it
Okay. Alright.
Okay
Well
You guys suuuuuuuuuuuckk
You guys suuuuuuuck
But anyway, that's ToyBox Demo.
I haven't screamed my voice out in a while so that was actually really intense.
So if you guys want to play this for yourselves, I'll put a link in the description below.
Maybe there's more levels because I don't think I met that guy on the right
If you want to see more of this let me know in the comments below.
And yes, I will get back to all the series that I'm supposed to do;
Event[0], OneShot, the other one that I've done, Rain World. I'll get them all done, and more Subnautica on the way very soon.
Thank you again everybody for watching. Lemme know what you thought in the comments below and, as always,
I will see YOU, in the next video. Buh-bye!
*Outro music*